on va voir si c'est vrai on va vous
faire l'interview comme tout le monde
jean louis aubert est que comme tout le
monde vous descendez vos poubelles vous
même le soir non est ce que comme tout
le monde vous chanter sous la douche par
exemple ouais je suis enchanté que la
douche c'est dans une chorale quand
j'étais non mais donc je chantais des
chansons au fond des bois
j'entends la voix dit qu'il ya là aussi
on avait un qui est bas j'ai beaucoup
fait pour des mois encore mélodie mais
est ce que comme tout le monde vous
pensez que jean-loup verte pourrait
baisser un peu plus faible ouais ouais
est ce que comme tout le monde vous
acheter que des best-of jean louis
aubert c'est vrai que l'on a j'en achète
ces raisons à cette malheureusement et
est ce que comme tout le monde vous
télécharger sur internet
non pas trop pas trop trop est ce que
comme tout le monde de les chanter
restera que pour faire plaisir à votre
maison de disques dans la maison 10 me
demande pas ça mais j'ai une très bonne
maison de disque mais sympa je serai
plus que comme tout le monde
jean louis aubert et des filles avec
lesquelles je n'ai jamais réussi à
coucher ouais combien bras beaucoup va
se chercher assez timide mais par contre
beaucoup de filles à qui j'ai envie de
coucher quand même encore
tous les horaires le
et hop